CONGRESSMAN, THANK YOU.
CONGRESSMAN.
I HOPE YOU WILL ANNOUNCE IN THE
FUTURE.
JOURNALIST IN NEW YORK CITY,
HOME OF BROOKLYN AND PEOPLE WHO
WRITE BUZZFEED, AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
CHADWICK, I KNOW I'M PAINTING
WITH A BROAD BRUSH, BUT I CAN
KIND OF PICTURE THE STAFFER IN
QUESTION SNEERING AT THE MIDDLE
OF THE COUNTRY AND BLINDING AN
ENTIRE GROUP BASED ON THEIR SKIN
COLOR, WHICH I THOUGHT WAS NOT
ALLOWED.
>> RIGHT.
I DON'T BELIEVE YOUR GUEST FOR
SATIRE.
TO MAKE FUN OF RACISM.
IT'S EXACTLY I THINK HOW YOU
PAINTED IT.
THE SORT OF LIBERAL OBERLIN KIDS
WHO GRADUATED TO LIVE IN
BROOKLYN AND FOR SOME REASON
WANT TO BELIEVE IN THE SORT OF
DISMANTLE THE WEALTH NARRATIVE.
I THINK THE WAY TO DO THAT IS TO
ATTACK WHITE PEOPLE.
MARXISM, IT'S SOCIALISM.
IT HAS THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA'S
EAR, MAINSTREAM SOCIETY'S EAR.
WHEN YOU SEE THESE PEOPLE WHO
OBSESS OVER VICTIMHOOD SO MUCH,
IT'S SO FASCINATING BECAUSE IF
YOU WANT TO SEE RACISM
EVERYWHERE, IF YOUR BRAIN WANTS
TO SEE RACISM EVERYWHERE, OR
THAT'S THE WORLD YOU WILL LIVE
IN.
I WAS HAVING A CONVERSATION WITH
BLACK WOMAN AND SHE WAS TALKING
ABOUT HOW BADLY SHE GETS TREATED
LIVE FOR ONE DAY AS A WHITE
WOMAN AND YOU WERE TREATED THE
EXACT SAME WAY?
PEOPLE WERE JUST AS RUDE TO YOU,
WHAT THEN?
>> Tucker: IT DOESN'T MAKE
ANYBODY HAPPIER TO SEE
EVERYTHING THROUGH THAT LENS.
I PERSONALLY MISSED IT BUT IT'S
IN THE TAPE, MAYBE YOU SAW IT,
COHOST JOY BEHAR REACTED TO THE
ONGOING PROTEST WE'VE BEEN
SEEING IN IRAN BY SAYING THE
U.S. IS ON THE VERY BRINK OF
EXECUTING GAY PEOPLE IN THE
STREET.
>> IT'S NOT APPLES AND APPLES,
COUNTRY TOWARDS THROWING
DEMOCRACY OUT THE WINDOW.
>> WE HAVE TO DEFEND THE PRESENT
CIVIL RIGHTS.
>> WE DO, BUT NOT BEING STONED
THINK WE ARE TO A COUNTRY WHERE
PEOPLE ARE STONED IN THE STREETS
WERE BEING GAY AS JOY BEHAR
ALL THE TIME, WE CAN'T EVEN GET
HAVE UNTIL THE SECOND TERM.
SHE IS COMPLETELY RIDICULOUS.
THERE'S NO PROOF TO IT.
IT'S SUCH A LOAD OF BULL.
IN THAT SAME DISCUSSION SHE WAS
SO-CALLED WOMEN'S MERGERS HERE,
THE RESIST PROTESTERS, SHE
THING.
SHE SAID THE DETAILS ARE
DIFFERENT ABOUT WHAT THEY ARE
FIGHTING AGAINST, BUT THE
GENERAL THING, THEY WANT
DEMOCRACY AND FREEDOM AND OURS
IS DEEPLY UNDER ATTACK IN THIS
COUNTRY.
FIRSTLY, LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT.
IN IRAN YOUNG WOMEN TEARING OFF
THEIR HEADSCARVES IN THERE FOR
JOBS AND HERE IN NEW YORK AND
LIBERATION.
AND WHEN SHE SAYS -- IT'S SO
FUNNY TO SEE HER SAYING OUR
DEMOCRACY IS UNDER ATTACK.
>> Tucker: IT SUCH GROTESQUE
OVERSTATEMENT.
I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO GET HIM
OUT ON TELEVISION, BUT PART OF
YOUR BRAIN SAYS PULL BACK A
GROTESQUELY, BECAUSE IF YOU DO
YOU WILL BE CALLED ON IT.
NO ONE EVER CALLS ANYBODY ON THE
LEFT WHEN THEY SAY LUDICROUS
THINGS LIKE GAYS ARE ABOUT TO BE
>> EXACTLY.
IT'S JUST THIS HYSTERIA AND THEY
HAVE NO EVIDENCE FOR IT.
THEY HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO EVIDENCE
FOR IT AND IT'S EXACTLY -- THEY
ARE JUST SHOWING WHAT THEY ARE,